partners and the city of toronto
this has truly been a city-wide effort
as we've worked closely with all areas
of the public sector to secure the city
finally i would like to acknowledge the
members of the toronto police service
and all the units and at all ranks they
have been working diligently
either road closures or the increased
presence of uniform police officers can
be cert sorry can be concerning to those
local residents and businesses
as we did last weekend we will do our
very best to balance our need to ensure
public safety and causing minimal
disruption as possible
we appreciate the patience of everyone
and we are hopeful this level of
cooperation will continue throughout the
coming weekend
as the chief has mentioned i will be on
the ground again this weekend and i will
be available to provide updates as
needed thank you
thank you lauren i'll now invite mayor
torrey to mission command
well thank you chief ramer and
superintendent pogue for the update
ahead of this weekend and for working to
make sure that the public has as much of
the information as the police can make
public on this issue
i'm here at the police headquarters
today to make sure that people know of
my continued support as mayor for the
work that our police service is doing in
partnership with the city to protect our
city
this is an extremely troubling time for
the country i know people are upset by
what they're seeing and what they're
experiencing everyone including me is
very frustrated by the length and the
overall impact of this pandemic we just
want to be over and we just want to get
back to our lives as we knew them and i
know those who have been directly
occupied those who've been directly
impacted by these illegal occupations
are beyond being upset
people are not upset by peaceful legal
respectful process they're not i've seen
that over and over again in this city
and elsewhere even when they disagree
with the reason for protests they see
peaceful respectful process for what it
is a crucial part of a healthy democracy
but what we are seeing goes way beyond
that way beyond peaceful and respectful
and way outside of the law and that has
people including me upset beyond the
frustration of the pandemic itself
there's enough frustration from the
pandemic people are losing jobs they're
losing time out of their lives they're
losing their rights to go about their
own lives peacefully and safely
all of this is so unfair to them and i
want those whose lives are being turned
upside down by all of this to know that
i feel very sad for everything that
they're going through and we're trying
to do everything we can
to deal with that as mayor of canada's
largest city i support the government of
canada and the government of ontario
working together to do all that they can
to support police in bringing an end to
this i want to thank premier ford for
declaring a state of emergency
in ontario today he was extremely clear
that it is time for these illegal
occupations to end and for people to go
home
it's time
it's time when looked at within the
frame of everyone else's rights and it's
time in terms of the overall well-being
of our country and our founding mantra
our founding mantra as a country peace
order and good government
we are so close to the end of this
pandemic we've made it through the
omicron surge ontario has set a clear
path forward the province has stated
that when public health restrictions
will be over they've stated when this
will happen there's a calendar there's
dates and times and places
and they'll be indicating at the same
time when those temporary restrictions
will come to an end because millions of
people including more than 2.5 million
people right here in the city of toronto
have done the right thing and got
vaccinated and that's why that timetable
is going to be met
the people who got vaccinated are
themselves the ones ending this pandemic
and i want to thank the vast majority of
people who have done the right thing and
who keep doing the right thing
last weekend toronto police worked
carefully and capably and i could use
other adjectives in terms of their
professionalism their confidence and
their steadiness to keep our residents
in this city of toronto safe during the
convoy protests
i am thankful for that good police work
that happened under the capable
leadership of chief raymond and all of
his command and for the fact that they
kept the hospitals that surround queen's
park safe not just the hospitals but all
of our frontline healthcare workers and
all of the patients and all the people
and neighborhoods who make up the three
million people who live here
those who showed up to protest were by
all accounts almost all accounts
peaceful and respectful and i'm thankful
for that too
as i said last week peaceful and
respectful protest is how we do things
here peaceful and respectful just how we
do things
now we anticipate or at least have to be
ready for another protest this weekend
we deal with protests almost every
weekend in this city and that's not a
complaint
police have taken action as properly
they should have to prepare for this
weekend and i continue to support the
work they're doing and the efforts they
will undertake to try to ensure that we
have another peace peaceful and safe
weekend in this city the city will
provide every bit of support that it can
in that regard
it is my continued hope if people are
determined to gather again to protest in
toronto that a commitment to peaceful
protest will be fully demonstrated fully
demonstrated
that people once they have exercised
their rights will recognize the rights
of their fellow citizens and return
peacefully to their homes knowing that
their views have been registered
the city continues to provide full
support as it will to the police to
prepare for this weekend and i'll say
once again i support chief raymer and
the women and men of the toronto police
service 100
in their work to keep this city peaceful
and safe
we all want to do everything we can
absolutely everything we can to try and
avoid the situations that we're seeing
in ottawa and in windsor
two cities where i have stayed in touch
with their mayors to offer support
during very challenging times for them
we want everyone to be safe and while
elected officials can't direct the
police and properly so i am here today
to help to deliver a message loudly and
clearly that illegal behavior or any
actions that threaten public safety
cannot be tolerated in the city of
toronto
again if you're planning to come here
for a protest that is not peaceful and
that is not respectful i would urge you
on behalf of all toronto residents and
businesses most sincerely to please just
stay away from our city
and please reconsider that planned
behavior even if it is just out of
respect for your fellow citizens let
alone respect for the rule of law
i know the road closures put in place
are disruptive to some residents and
businesses though my experience last
weekend was people in the city of
toronto understood that and they
accepted the need for that
this is about public safety in general
and protecting our hospitals and
everyone who works there and every
resident of the city of toronto
including people who seek care in those
hospitals
i want to again be absolutely clear that
i support toronto police taking
necessary action to prepare for protests
with a focus on doing everything they
can to protect the safety of toronto
residents and businesses and to minimize
any disruptions to toronto residents and
businesses to the greatest possible
extent
and i want to reiterate my firm beliefs
that and these are police that i believe
are shared by the vast majority of
toronto residents people should not be
blocked from receiving emergency care or
any medical care and hospital workers of
all kinds should be able to freely and
safely come and go from their workplaces
businesses have every right to be open
and not to be disrupted
residents who live here should not have
their ability to enjoy a safe and
peaceful life unduly impacted
i know that we will get through this
weekend again and the days to come and i
know that as a country we will get
through these incredibly challenging
times
once we do i think it will be timely and
very necessary to try to have a long
careful reflection on the polarization
we're seeing in a country admired for
its ability to work things through
collectively time after time year after
year i want to thank toronto residents
and businesses for their continued
patience and understanding i know that
that patient's understanding isn't
endless and i very much want to thank
once again all the police officers and
city staff who are working to keep our
city and all of its residents safe we
will get through this thanks to their
hard work and dedication to duty our
city is strong it is understanding it is
peace loving and it is respectful and
may those qualities prevail at a very
challenging time thank you gene
thank you we'll now take questions so
when you're called on please unmute your
mic at this time only and please
indicate who your question is for so
chief james raymer mayor john tory or
staff superintendent lauren po you'll
have one question
and follow up once you've asked your
question you'll be muted again
so first we have chris glover from cbc
chris do you have a question
yes i do and this first one is for the
chief i believe um
my question is are police going solely
off of social media posts or have you
guys actually spoken to organizers of
this anticipated protest in toronto
because i just got off the phone with
one of the people who identified himself
as one of the toronto area organizers of
the original protest convoy and he said
that this anticipated toronto protest
actually has nothing to do with them
that those social media posts were spam
or misdirects so the big question here
is how is toronto police getting its
intel here and what is police expecting
to see in terms of what this anticipated
protest will actually look like who will
be there and if it will include large
vehicles like trucks or not
well thank you for the question
the first thing i will say is that our
intelligence is not based merely on
social media posts we have a very
elaborate and robust intelligence
operation that incorporates the entire
province and all the agencies within
that province
at both the municipal provincial and
federal level so our intelligence is
actually quite robust
i'm not going to go into specifically
what it is but uh
i can assure you that is very robust
thank you and chris do you have a
follow-up
yeah i do this one is for the chief and
also uh mayor tory if you could weigh in
on this one as well um the question here
is what is an acceptable protest first
when is it time to step in i mean if
protesters are trying to dig in and stay
here like we've seen in windsor and in
ottawa what's the threshold or the
timeline for when police and local
authorities will step in and stop it
well perhaps i should start with that uh
what i will say to you is that we are
here to preserve public safety and
facilitate peaceful protest and peaceful
protest does not include vehicles
jamming up the roadways so
we will facilitate any type of protest
tomorrow as we do week in and week out
throughout the year uh that one that
people want to do that protest
peacefully but again where i can tell
you from and that's why we've engaged in
the activities we've had that we are
doing and are currently doing to not
have the roadways and seats of
government jammed up and occupied so
that's what we're attempting to stop and
will not be tolerated
i'll just say that i think a lot of
people a lot of the time have a very uh
have a hard time understanding the
difficulty that's involved in the
discretion that is exercised by all
police everywhere in carrying over
duties because they precisely have to
answer a question just like that as to
when it is enough too much
but i i will say
that i think when we see instances where
and i've talked a lot this week about
the fact that there are many sets of
rights that have to be taken into
account yes there are the rights of
people to peaceful and hopefully
respectful protests and the words
peaceful and respectful are an important
part of that but those have to be you
know weighed against and it's part of
the difficulty that police have to
engage in day in and day out the rights
of other people to go about their
business to go to work to go to the
hospital without harassment to go to
work at the hospital without harassment
to just move about their city to live in
peace and quiet
and so
there there comes a time you know and
it's hard to measure whether it's
minutes hours or days there comes a time
when it's just too much
and i think as i said earlier when
premier ford declared the state of
emergency today it's time some people
would say it was time before now but
it's certainly time now and uh i think
that is part of what the police have to
decide and they're very difficult and
important responsibilities
thank you austin delaney from ctp news
do you have a question
i do it's for the chief uh chief what is
your intelligence telling you what kind
of numbers can we expect are you looking
at people number of people are you
looking at trucks number of trucks
oh i i'm not going to really discuss the
specific intelligence austin but we are
preparing for every eventuality and we
have a very robust plan
that uh is very nimble and allows us to
scale up or scale down whatever is
required
and if chief if they start to look like
they're going to park and stay for a
while um what's the plan there do you
plan on towing them to how will you move
people out we're going to help them
leave
and what does that mean
well we put we've as we have assets in
place to make sure if people are
if vehicles are engaged and they're
they're they're not moving we're going
to move them out of the way
thank you austin
next we have wendy gillis from the star
wendy go ahead with your question
thank you so much this question is for a
staff superintendent poke as well as to
framer i'm just wondering how you are
sorting through sort of the
misinformation that might be coming your
way around uh threats of arrival of
protesters how are you determining
determining what's legitimate and and
what's you know sort of a part of a game
as some of the organizers have said uh
this week
thank you wendy uh again as the chief
has says i i said i don't really want to
comment on specific intelligence but i
can tell you that we certainly uh we
look at all of the intelligence coming
in and we certainly uh try to source
that uh for credibility um as well as
working with uh all of the law
enforcement partners across the province
as well to determine uh you know what we
what to expect here and again as the
chief said we do have a plan and uh we
plan for many different uh scenarios and
we're prepared for that
actually wendy i will comment it and
it's actually a very good question there
is we know deliberately a lot of
disinformation misinformation out there
that very much complicates the province
it is an organized group
of people um that are trying to make it
difficult for police agencies across
across the province we believe some of
them are deliberately trying to tax our
resources so
uh we have to weigh all the information
the best we can with all our partners
and do the best we can and that that's
what we're trying to do but you're
absolutely right that that strategy is
out there
go ahead could you follow us one day
thank you thank you so much for that
answer and and you did mention chief
just sort of drawing on resources i am
wondering if you can give us a sense of
what impact this is having on on
deployment i'm sure officers are being
pulled off their regular assignments can
you give us any sense of what the impact
this is happening having
yes we're uh another good question wendy
we are able to maintain our business
continuity uh throughout the city
we are
redeploying a plainclothes assets that
are now into uniform we of course have
people on overtime and callbacks we have
a lot of city assets that are assisting
us so it really is an all hands on deck
at all ranks civilians as well that are
assisting us in these operations you'll
notice our
uh you know our fleet services several
of our uh city of our toronto police
service tow trucks are out there as well
so we can move very very quickly if need
be so it really is an all hands on deck
approach but uh business continuity is
being in pain is being maintained uh and
we're collaborating very much with our
again our
our partners across the province and in
particular our gta partners
thank you next up we have mark
mcallister for city news mark do you
have a question
i do thank you it's for chief ramer as
well
you had said basically
we'll simply move them if they get in
the way i'm just curious
what that involves
exactly we're also saying subject to
enforcement so
what does enforcement mean how do you
move them
we have uh extremely well trained public
order personnel and op and and
commanders on the ground that will make
those determinations as the situation
develops uh what i will say is that we
are not going to allow encampments
that's priority one
well i shouldn't say it's prior it's
it's
our priority is to maintain the safety
of all the public and our hospitals and
that's why and the seats of government
but in terms of our strategies the
priority will be to allow peaceful
protests but not allow encampments and
to occupy roadways
do you have a follow-up mom
i do thank you
aside from what has been done to close
down the streets in and around queen's
park
are you prepared for anything happening
elsewhere in the city and what exactly
are you preparing for
we do have a perimeter uh that we will
shut down if need be in the downtown
core that that is primarily looking at
the the queen's park and city hall of
course and and some adjoining areas and
that will be our focus in the downtown
core to protect that area and to make
sure it's not occupied but again
even in within that area we will
facilitate peaceful protest
thank you next up we have mark douglas
from 680 mark do you have a question
uh thank you connie question for chief
raymer
we've heard some comments with new state
of emergency in ontario do you expect
the state of emergency and the crackdown
measure that it allows will make for a
reduced protest in toronto this weekend
or could it possibly just make the
convoy demonstrators mad and enslave the
whole situation
i i think it was an important decision
i'm pleased with the decision to enact
the state of emergency i mean we're
assessing the tools um that have been uh
given to us and and you know during the
course of any demonstration or protest
we'll evaluate and determine whether any
of them need to be implemented based on
what is happening but i can tell you
that anything that we do in that regard
will only be if
if necessary
would you rather follow up
yes thank you uh question for mayor
torrey you mentioned how common how
common it is to see protests in toronto
i think anyone who lives in toronto
would agree with you but i'd like to
know
just how you're feeling about all this
did you ever imagine you would see in
toronto such an extreme reaction as what
we've been seeing with convoy
demonstrators as they respond to what
they don't like about the the copen and
the pandemic protection measures is is
this whole convoy experience rather
stunning to you as a politician
if you'd ask me to imagine much of what
we've experienced during the pandemic i
couldn't have possibly done so in
advance of it actually happening but i
think that the nature of discourse
generally the nature of these kinds of
protests generally even the nature of
sometimes the commentary back and forth
between
the media and people in life and public
life has become much more polarized he's
become much sharper i don't think it's
good for the country i think that but
again bottom line is the same if people
are respectful and they're peaceful and
they understand that there's a limit to
how long you can stay in a given place
and continue to protest without
interfering with the rights of others
then you take life as it comes but i
think some of this has gone way beyond
that in all of those respects and so uh
you know it's our job just to deal with
reality as we find it and i think some
of this is you know cause for a very
serious reflection after this whole
pandemic is over about the direction in
which discourse discussion and protest
are going because i don't think it's a
good direction but you take it as it
counts
thank you next we have katie nicholson
from cbc katie do you have a question
katie if you have a question please
don't mute yourself
okay right
this is for superintendent pogue and for
chief ramer and just uh wondering last
weekend barge trucks encroached on that
barrier at avenue gorham park what have
you learned from from that specific
incident last week
well we uh we certainly are increasing
the uh the area of um road closures um
uh again we did have a number of trucks
there and a number of protesters that
descend on the area um but we were very
clear that we weren't going to allow
that to happen on a prolonged basis so
as i mentioned last week when uh you
know when it was safe to do so for both
the uh the residents in the area and our
police officers on the ground uh we did
move in and ask those uh protesters and
uh truck drivers to leave and we were we
did receive cooperation we did have
heavy toes in the area uh if we were
faced with any resistance but we were
able to clear the area and that's why
i've asked again
uh this weekend to have that cooperation
again
thank you
and you have a follow-up katie
yeah the protesters were able to learn a
lot
from police last weekend in terms of
what your mitigation efforts are
how do you plan for that for any kind of
counter planning that that protesters
might have to sort of circumvent the the
barriers and the planning measures that
you put in place
um
good question but i think i'll start
with saying that uh we have better
planners
and um
uh that's precisely what's involved we
have a very robust plan and some good
people so you asked about uh earlier
about a a learning point well one of the
things we learned about avenue road and
bloor is that we had small tourist
police vehicles there and there was a
concern at one point in time that the
large trucks were going to try to move
them out of the way slightly so they
could move further well you'll see now
that there are no small tourist vehicles
parked at avenue road in bloor and that
perimeter will expand so yeah we do
learn things when we maybe try to decide
what they are capable of or prepared to
do and so all of those things are taking
account into our planning and i'll just
emphasize again it's very adaptable it's
very nimble and i'm quite confident
we're prepared for any eventuality
thank you
our final
go to scott laurie at the toronto sun
scott do you have a question
uh yes i do thanks uh question for uh
chief ramer it's only been a few hours
since uh state of emergency was declared
uh by the premier what kind of
discussions have you had about
how that state of emergency
will
affect the response this weekend
that's a good question one of the first
things we did was engage our legal team
here in the service in the city to start
examining examining precisely what the
implications are of those changes and
how we might use them if we depending
upon what we are confronted with
so those discussions are underway once
we
are satisfied with the information we
receive we will prepare that information
in a form for our officers to understand
and and for our commanders to understand
and then like i say as i said earlier
we'll evaluate based on what is
happening on on how it might be used but
again
those type of things based on the
emergency will only be utilized uh if
absolutely necessary uh if it's the
usual peaceful protests that we
encounter in this city i don't see it
being i don't see it being required
and you have a follow-up style
just on on staffing we've heard that
some officers from the
gta have gone to windsor has toronto
been asked to provide any extra help in
windsor
this is uh what i might say what i will
say to you is this is a coordinated
provincial plan by all the police
services in ontario and we've created a
we have
created a regional approach quite
frankly and uh
we are not in windsor at this time
and that concludes today's news
conference thank you everyone who has
joined us today
oh